hands play an active and vital role in
our everyday living they help to express
tender devotion to our loved ones
to handle and care for the many objects
around us and to minister to our own
personal needs
but as useful as hands are they can also
serve as vehicles for spreading disease
agents from person to person and from
place to place the danger of spreading
infectious organisms is especially great
when caring for the sick and debilitated
whether in the hospital or in the home
not only are sick individuals highly
susceptible to infection they also serve
as sources of disease agents even though
the signs and symptoms of infection may
not be apparent when caring for the sick
the simplest way to prevent the spread
of agents is to conscientiously practice
hand-washing based on the fundamental
principles of medical asepsis the aim of
this technique is to reduce the number
of pathogenic organisms it must not be
confused with surgically sepsis where
elimination of all organisms is the goal
the primary principle of medically
sepsis involves mechanical removal of
dirt and microorganisms from the skin to
carry out this principle in hand-washing
certain essentials are required running
water
soaps and related compounds and friction
running water is an important element
since it acts to flush foreign material
off the hands the water temperature
should be that which is comfortable to
the skin while very hot water may
destroy some organisms it can also cause
chapping and breaks in the skin thereby
affording harborage for pathogenic
microorganisms infection may then occur
thus increasing the danger of hands as
spreaders of disease soaps and related
compounds do
to their detergent properties are also
effective in the mechanical cleansing of
hands soap lather from its water to
penetrate the skin pores and wash away
dirt another foreign matter
friction is still another aid in
mechanical removal of organisms and is
produced by vigorously rubbing together
the hands and fingers where frequent
hand-washing is necessary brushes are
not generally recommended since they
tend to injure and excoriate the skin
chemical destruction of microorganisms
or disinfection is a means of attaining
medically sepsis in hand-washing
it must be borne in mind however that
some chemicals will injure the hands
there are several soaps and detergents
containing chemicals like hexa
chlorophenol specific strengths which
serve to inhibit the growth of bacteria
without producing damage to the skin
finally the length and the frequency of
the hand wash is an important
consideration in achieving medically
sepsis before and after caring for each
patient a thorough hand wash out this is
also important at intervals during
patient care when there is danger of
spreading organisms from one part of the
body to another the length of the hand
wash depends upon the degree of
suspected hand contamination the use of
soap or detergent and the vigor of
friction applied one to two minutes is
generally recommended the demonstration
to follow involves a hand washing
procedure that can be used primarily in
hospitals equipped with foot controlled
water faucets and liquid soap dispensers
first it is important that patient care
personnel distinguish between the clean
and the contaminated objects in the
facility in this procedure we will
consider the clean objects to be hand
lotion paper towels put operated soap
dispenser and water faucet they will be
touched
only with clean hands the contaminated
objects are the sink Bowl and the used
nail cleaning sticks during the hand
wash the nurse should use body mechanics
which will permit comfortable operation
of the foot pedals and prevent her
uniform from touching the contaminated
sink her position should be such that
the soap lather and rinse water will
fall into the bowl and not on the floor
before the hand wash all jewelry except
a plain wedding band should be removed
from the hands and wrists finger nails
should be well groomed and nail-polish
should not be worn these precautionary
measures will eliminate additional
harborage areas for microorganisms the
area to be washed should extend
one inch beyond the line of
contamination in this case the mid
forearm first with the foot pedal turn
on the water and wet the hands
thoroughly
next apply liquid soap from the
dispenser working up a good lather by
rubbing together the palmar and dorsal
surfaces ten or more friction motions
are suggested
with the fingers that are laced continue
with about ten more friction motions
after a repeat rubbing of the Palmers
rinsed the hands thoroughly allowing the
water to flow off the sides next wet one
forearm and from the soap dispenser
apply liquid soap work up a lather
employing a rotary friction motion now
with the other forearm and repeat the
lathering as before
rinse both hands and forearms allowing
the water to flow from the finger tips
to the elbow once again soak the hands
and work up another lather
with an orange stick for the blood end
of a toothpick clean all fingernails
carefully rinsing the toothpick after
each finger the blunt end is used since
it lessens the possibility of injuring
the soft tissues under the nails it may
not always be necessary to clean the
nails each time the hands are washed
when finished
discard the toothpick and continue
rubbing the hands with a friction motion
now give both hands and forearms a
complete and final rinse
with a paper towel dry both hands and
one for arm from wrist to elbow using a
patting motion
with a clean towel again dry both hands
and the other forearm use additional
towels as needed to complete the hand
washing procedure always apply a lotion
to the hands and forearms this helps
keep the skin soft and free from
chapping
many hand-washing facilities frequently
do not have foot operated water faucets
and soap dispensers in such cases hand
operated faucets and cake soaps are used
these require a slight modification of
the hand-washing procedure the faucet
handles and the soap are considered to
be contaminated they should not be
touched with clean hands first wet the
hands thoroughly take the cake of soap
and work up a generous lather using the
same friction motion as demonstrated
earlier retain the soap and the hands
throughout the procedure
rinse the hands again allowing the water
to flow off the sides now wet and soak
each forearm transfer the soap from hand
to hand between each lathering operation
after a thorough rinse of each forearm
soak the hands once again
holding the soap by the fingertips rinse
and let drop into soap container
continue washing the hands and cleaning
the nails ending the procedure with a
drying of both hands and forearms with
the last paper towel
turn off the water faucets the towel
will prevent recontamination of the
hands by the faucet handles in caring
for sick and debilitated patients it may
not always be possible to carry out hand
washing procedures in which the
principles of medically sepsis can be
applied in such cases improvised methods
are necessary in order to remove as much
dirt and contamination as possible for
example when caring for a patient in
isolation and where running water from a
faucet is not available in the room an
assistant may pour water over the hands
during the hand wash in some situations
it may be necessary to wash in a soap
solution or other chemical this method
however is undesirable since mechanical
removal of organisms by running water
cannot be achieved emergencies may arise
where there is no water available here
swabbing or rinsing the hands with 70%
alcohol may provide a relative measure
of cleanliness as expedience these
improvised measures should be used only
in emergency or disaster situations a
more desirable hand-washing should be
carried out as soon as possible
a conscientious practice of hand washing
whether done in the hospital the home or
under emergency conditions is a vital
function in providing safer nursing care
for the sick and debilitated it is
considered one of the most effective
means for preventing and controlling the
spread of disease producing organisms
all those specific procedures and
techniques of hand washing may vary the
basic principles of medically sepsis
should remain constant if the details of
the procedures are kept simple and
practical effective hand-washing can be
performed
you